good morning everybody how are we good
good it's good to see some familiar
faces out there my name is Scott Allen
and this is an opinionated approach to
asp.net core what I did to prepare for
this presentation is go back and look at
some of the projects that I've been
working on to the last year year and a
half and just take notes on what I liked
and what I didn't like that we did or I
did and I came up with the list of 56
items which I thought was a little bit
too aggressive for a one-hour session so
I cut it back to a list of 50 items
which means we'll be moving along pretty
good and so some things I'll cover
pretty quickly but if you have any
questions you can always email me and I
went through that list then once I got
it down to 50 items and I broke it into
some different categories like how do I
want to organize solutions and projects
what techniques that I liked what didn't
I like how to organize startup code and
like the code that goes inside of
start-up CS to configure it your
application some tips about and opinions
about controllers about writing client
code because we're all using JavaScript
code now on the client about writing
c-sharp code with asp.net core views and
writing unit tests so we'll just get
started with some of the boring things
like solutions and projects so we can
build up a crescendo and have a very
exciting finish yes solutions and
projects how do you organize them with
dotnet core I rather like the approach
the Microsoft is take in if you look in
any other github repositories for any of
their projects you'll see things like a
solution file that is right in the root
of the directory so it makes it nice and
easy to be able to find that solution
when you clone the repository and just
go into the folder and double click that
and there's always a top-level source
folder that can contain one or more
projects and a top-level test folder to
contain one more unit test so if you
really look around a lot of the open
source projects that deal with dotnet
core they follow the same sort of
pattern so I want to use that same sort
of pattern even for business
applications that are not as a source it
just make sense to people that are
accustomed to this environment now and
then I'll throw in a few additional
folders so I might throw in a folder for
documentation
reasonable and the one thing to be
careful about here we probably
experienced this is if you go into a
solution like in the window here and
right click on a solution and say add a
new solution folder the solution
Explorer in visual studio doesn't
faithfully represent the physical
location of this files on the file
system that folder that I create the all
these folders that I create are just
logical containers and if I add a file
to it it just goes into the root of the
project or somewhere so you just have to
be careful to right-click and add these
folders and then go out to the hard
drive and do a make directory to create
that physical folder and then add items
from that folder some of the other
things that I like to check in if it's
an open source project for example or if
it's a library and I want to demonstrate
how to use this library include a
samples folder Microsoft does this quite
often in fact one of the best ways to
learn about some of the features of the
middleware and the various components to
go into asp.net core is actually go to
the github repository and look at their
unit tests and look inside of their
sample for for example the mmm ESPN app
security samples contain how to use
things like cookie authentication
middleware at a low level and those are
interesting to read because sometimes
they're better than the documentation
and they give you code that you can just
start playing with some other things
that I always want to check in are some
scripts development scripts to help
developers work from the command line so
if you're using something like entity
framework or and you have to run
migrations then you might want to do
that from the command line which means
you run dotnet EF migrations ad and all
that stuff what I will do is create a
script folder and check some scripts in
so the developers just need to go to the
command line and type add migration and
an email of migration and behind the
scenes it takes care of all the
parameters that have to go to that
dotnet executable and you can write this
in PowerShell you can write there some
bash you can write commands files
whatever your environment that you're
developing in whatever works and
whatever your team is happy with
in an example of like ad migration would
be I just type ad migration foo and it
will go out and do the net EF migrations
ad it will do the dot nest dotnet es
database update and then I'm just ready
to go with this thing
I'll also check in deployment scripts so
if you're using Azure one approach might
be to download the azure resource
manager template and a PowerShell script
that azor can produce when you just
right-click on a resource group and say
I wanna or go to the automation script
for a resource group and say just give
me a script to automate the deployment
of all of this I will take those
templates in that PowerShell file and
check it into a deployment folder inside
of Visual Studio and that I can use
inside of a build process or my
deployment process and developers can
use it locally when they need to set up
an environment and Azure to be able to
work with the project and you might also
consider it to like tear form which is
very good at automating infrastructure
across multiple platforms so it supports
Azure and its port AWS and it supports a
number of other environments builds I
also believe should be checked in the
source control so if you go out to use a
build system in the cloud something like
a fair or something like Visual Studio
King services in the cloud there's a way
to graphically define your build
environment where you go into the UI and
you select a couple check boxes and you
say here's my solutions build and it
just does a bunch of magic behind the
scenes but as far as app there goes
anyone use out there it's a nice system
you can go into a play and you say okay
I've set up my configuration now gives
me a yeah mol file that describes the
configuration that I just entered and I
can download that file and check it in
the source control and now all of my
build configuration even though I can't
build quite like a player locally my
build configuration is at least under
source control and it's version
controlled and I can see what it's been
changing and what I'll typically do is
just come up with a PowerShell script to
do the build dotnet builds so far have
been reasonably simple you know you can
just do not never store dotnet build net
run my tests dotnet packed and then
developers can also use that script
locally if you want to build
if we need to debug something that went
wrong in a fair anyone using visual
studio team services formerly Visual
Studio online some working name like
that they have that nice graphical build
environment where you can just say I
want to add another build step and drop
in something that says build my solution
star that SLM and I think that's very
good but I would like again a script
that I can check into source control for
that build and I would like I would like
something where developers locally can
use that same script to build on their
machine and that way I know that when
that script is checked in to be s online
that it has a reasonably good chance of
working there and you can do that by
going into a task catalog there's
various tasks in there just to run a
PowerShell script or a command script
and there's even plug-ins for cake and
tea sake if you use those types of build
pools and descript everything kind of
avoid this graphical environment for
anything but maybe the simplest projects
just the kind of information you were
expecting by the way we're going to see
some people wondering about it I do
believe that trading too many projects
as a problem sometimes with thought net
solutions I like to start with just a
core set of projects maybe one for the
web application one for my core logic
one for unit tests and then just see
where it goes from there too many
projects have a tendency to make special
studio unhappy once you get over a
gigabyte of memory it starts to slow
everything down let's talk about startup
2 for a minute when I look at a startup
top CS file in an asp.net core project I
think that it has three responsibilities
the three responsibilities are typically
configure the configuration system in
other words tell me if I'm using app
settings that Jason and environment
variables and all of that and then
there's configuring the container which
is that configure services method and
then there's the configure method which
is building your HTTP processing
pipeline is putting all the middleware
in place so that your application can
process HTTP per class and I've seen a
few startups ES files and non-trivial
projects start to grow a little bit out
of control
so I came up with some opinions about
that first of all a lot of the examples
that you look at for asp.net core for
some reason they will do this logging
configuration that you see here at the
bottom they'll do that inside of
configure right before all of the
middleware is configured and to me that
always makes no sense the startup method
the configure method is for middleware
so I usually move all of my logging
configuration into the constructor for
the startup class so we'll set up our
configuration and put in the different
JSON files that we need and then just
configure the logger right away and it's
ready to go throughout the rest of the
startup file the other thing I believe
is to keep it clean so inside of
configure services when you're
configuring the container for asp.net
for some of the services that you add
are quite complicated they come up a lot
of options so for example this first
line here add customized MVC that
replaced 20 or 30 lines of configuration
that used to be inside of here that
would do things like provide a custom
configuration for the razor view to make
it look for folders in a specific file
there's all these configuration options
for NBC what I would prefer to do is to
go into the startup ops ES file and just
be a high-level overview of what this
application is using so I'm using MVC I
have some security features I have
mediator I have some data stores and
then each of those methods is just an
extension method defined in another file
to move all of this code outside of the
startup file so add customized MVC is
just an extension method by service
collection and it all just works that
way the one exception to this rule is in
middleware but so I do believe when
you're configuring middle layer and try
to the configure method again I want to
be able to glance at it and see a
high-level overview of the modules that
are installed if you have to do any
special configuration for that
middleware passing options objects and
things like that I would rather make an
extension method to do that but I do
allow the configure method to branch so
I want it to be apparent that if we're
in development we're using these three
pieces of middleware but when we're in
production we're using this different
piece of middleware that will behave a
little bit differently and I
I think that starting another thing that
I've had some success with is making use
of my net web application as an
executable because in.net core I can run
my web application from the command
prompt and ostensibly that's to launch
it as a server so it listens on the port
but you can also exit before it actually
starts running so there's some things
that you might want to do particularly
in development that your web application
can do other than just responding to
HTTP requests and then an example of
that would be perhaps Auto migrating a
database using some migration scripts or
feeding a database if I'm in development
and I just created a database and it has
no data in it and again if you go out
and look at several solutions to they're
sort of out there on the internet a lot
of people will do those sort of box do
that sort of work inside of the startup
class which kind of makes sense because
that's where the application starts or
it sounds like where the application
starts but really the application starts
and static void mean and if I can do
work like that inside of process BD
commands before the application actually
starts booting up and listening to web
requests I would prefer it to happen
here and I have an example of what
process DD commands could look like
which is this and I just want to call
your attention to the top line of code
if you can see it you can see in the
back oh yes so what this code wants to
do is before we even get into the
startup class I want to be able to do
things like drop a database and recreate
it and do the migrations in order to do
that I am going to need to get a
reference to a service code factory so
that I can use that to get a reference
to the repository the entity framework
DB contacts whatever you're using for
data access and it's very important to
actually use this I service scope
factory an instance of that if you're
doing any side of any kind of work
outside of an HTTP request because if
you have a dependency registered in the
caner that is not supposed to be a
singleton so it's a transient dependency
or so
well it's go to an HTTP for class let's
say or created for instance if you get
one of those things outside the scope of
an HTTP request you can end up with a
singleton for the lifetime of the
application and this I service code this
bit of code right here that gets a nice
service code factory will help you avoid
that situation will create a new scope
will go out and get the dependencies
that we need and then we'll do things
like drop the database migrate the
database see the database with data
making any sense okay and to facilitate
that I would probably check in a script
to the scripts folder so a developer
when I'm at the command prompt I can
just type recreate DD and it will go out
and dotnet run my application and just
pass along the parameters so it'll drop
the database migrate it feed it and then
I actually want to stop I don't want it
to launch the server when I do those
commands
Oh for parking arguments oh yeah you
could do that if it got complicated I
was trying to do the simplest possible
thing that would work until it got too
complicated yeah so the question was
what I use any of the libraries for
flushing command line arguments and
things like that and this could be very
helpful
yes longer recommendations I really
liked fever log how many people have
used that a few so it plugs right into
asp.net core there's a new get package
you just download and you write some
code to configure sphere log in fact the
startup code we looked at earlier was
configuring sphere log and there's two
nice things about it first of all it's
structured events so there's a special
syntax here in sphere log that allows
you to given some objects like position
I actually went to serialize that entire
object into my log and sira log will
take care of that that's one nice
feature the other nice feature was fear
log is it has so many sinks that it can
go to you can write to a sequel server
database you can write to a rolling file
you can write to add your table storage
there's a list of 20 30 or 40 additional
NuGet packages you can install just to
have sphere log write information
somewhere that you want aqua dotnet
actors all sorts of things so we
fantastic and you can control all of
that well here we go through JSON
configuration or through configuration
and code so this would just be a way of
telling sphere logs I want to write to a
rolling file so it's going to be the
format of the file so to be log - and a
date Jason and after that everything
that this log will go into that file for
the day so asp.net core comes with a
container where you can register
services you can register them as
Singleton's you can register them as
transient and it's really pretty good
for a lot of applications with
everything you need but you could
consider using a more fully featured
container something like a structure map
or an inject something like that because
there are some scenarios that are quite
nice for the container some features a
fully featured container can provide
that are quite nice things like all the
discovery and decorators decorators are
a big one so a structure with a
you got like poor there's no way for me
to say given us interface I agree when
you construct an instance of that I also
want to decorate it with this other
class like the cashing reader will suck
them out you can do things like that and
set up interception and also I have
Diagnostics structure map provides a
nice Diagnostics where you can basically
ask it how are you configured and what
will happen if I ask for this how are
you going to resolve this service
forming and structure Maps fairly easy
to plug in that's actually an example of
decoration anytime you resolve an eye
widget decorate it with a widget folder
and we will use a widget but at one time
it'll be decorated with a folder going
quickly so project structure once you
get inside of a specific project what
are some things to look for a few years
ago Jimmy bells are did a presentation
at NDC I think we're at NDC owsla though
about asp.net applications implemented
with vertical feature slices anyone ever
see that one it's a good presentation to
watch and feature folders in general
anyone here feature folders this is
something I started using after I saw
Jimmy's presentation and Curtin talked
about it a bit I have a hard time now
walking up to an asp.net MVC application
and seeing top level folders of
controllers views and models it
irritates me it's a what Uncle Bob might
call the screaming architecture like the
layout of the project of screening that
this is an MVC application I would much
rather organize the application around
the features that it's going to
implement so if I'm building an
accounting system I might have a I want
to have a features older that would
provide me account management
administration and actually this is for
golfers apparently maybe my API that
some Java Script uses some shared stuff
but I like this for a few reasons one is
it really allows me to think about
partitioning my application by feature
instead of artificially putting views in
one folder and controllers in another
folder and it's very easy here now to
keep it controller
and the views that that controller is
going to use in the same folder as well
as any view models that that controller
that are specific to that controller and
it's a very nice organization because it
makes things easier to find and
typically when you go in to make a
change in an application you're working
one a feature and so to go into a
feature folder and have nearly
everything that you need right there
I think it's been advantageous the other
thing I like is it can mimic the
hierarchy of the UI so if I actually
look at the UI for this application
someone clicks on the top-level admin
link and then they're given another menu
that says do you want to manage this or
manage that or manage this and so I can
have nested folders inside of there but
there can still be notice this admin
controller the kind of controls that
top-level feature how do you do this in
asp.net core it requires very little
codes and by the way I've had several
frustrating attempts trying to rewrite
those account controllers in asp.net
core and I'll get as far as creating a
log in log out controller and the
register controller and trying to break
it out it's just very cumbersome someday
that'll be a new get package that I can
put together I hope the code to
implement feature folders is relatively
straightforward and what I did one day
is just put it into a new get package
and publish their own new gap its ode to
code add feature folders once you
install that package when you're inside
of configure services all you do is all
you need to do to use this is to say
services MVC add feature folders and now
you can place your controllers and views
inside of a top level features folder
make them so controller code I like to
think of controllers as purely facades
so that they should do as little work as
possible and have as little a little
code as possible inside of them which
I'll come to in a minute I do like the
routing attribute route in asp.net core
their first-class feature now they're
very flexible they don't have some of
the quirks that were around in MVC 5 and
so every controller that I write now
will use a rel attribute say to reach
this controller you have to go to admin
/ manage mash map
is slash and then an action that's
inside of here and I like this for a few
reasons one is I can make parameter
names like season ID match up with what
the action is actually expecting I don't
just have to have a generic ID parameter
which I often find very confusing when
there's an ID parameter to every action
and I don't know if that's supposed to
be an account ID or a golfer ID or
employee ID what is it supposed to be
and if you I'm assuming a lot of people
have used asp.net core and you know that
these special tokens for square brackets
that allows asp.net core just to replace
the name of this controller inside of
that route so you don't have to hard to
manage matches inside of there I'm a big
fan of mediator
so another Jenny product of Jimmy Bogart
mine what mediator allows me to do so
here's what I went from a controller I
mentioned this earlier I want to control
her to be a facade
I want to control her to only be
responsible for receiving an HTTP
request and sending out a response but
doing nothing in between
just dispatch something and I actually
really liked the web api back when it
back when it was web api to when you
actually we're working with abstractions
like HTTP request message an HTTP
response message because that's what i
think a controller is really doing it's
receiving overclass and sending out a
response asp.net core we don't have
those types unless you install the web
api compatibility shim but i'm okay to
live with this is a controller that
takes a command that's been be
serialized from the incoming request for
me and now all I really want to do with
that command is maybe I'll do some basic
checks like model state is valid Jimmy
doesn't like that but I'm okay with it
all the work though all the work happens
in meteor so I don't want the controller
touching any sort of business service or
repository or context or do anything
other than maybe with a logging service
I just want to dispatch things through
mediator tell me anyone using mediator
whew
so check that project out it's really
easy to set up what you do is you set up
I don't think I have any code here
unfortunately you basically create
queries or commands you dispatch them
using mediator mediator will find the
associated handler for this particular
command and it will just do work and
return you a result it's perfect throw
away the account controller yes this is
trying to lift the account controller it
Scrolls off the bottom of the screen
just trying to lift the manage
controller that's the exact opposite of
what I want a controller to look like
just range and reams and reams of code
inside a controller action it's very
difficult to look at a lot of people
asking you about cross-site request
forgeries in aspx or and yes obviously
it's still a problem so if you have an
app and a lot of people ask me how how
do I if I if I'm building an API with
the asp.net core how can I get a token
to my JavaScript ur to send along to
prevent a fee surf at at so this is
something you have to worry about if you
have an application where the
authentication happens implicitly and
automatically so an example would be
cookie authentication so you're building
a full web application and a part of
that web app application our API
endpoints the JavaScript calls and
because you're using cookie
authentication the browser will
automatically authenticate the user by
sending that cookie along another
example would be Windows authentication
it happens there too so how do you get a
cookie into JavaScript I usually set up
an xsrf token controller this is just
injecting the int anti for jury service
and I can walk up to that service and I
can tell it to get in-store tokens
that'll actually do two things right
there the first thing it will do is
issue a set cookie header to the client
to make sure that there is a cookie
would be one part of the xsrf sodium and
it will also return to me a data
structure that will tell me the request
token that my JavaScript needs to
include as well as the header name that
I need to place that token into so just
return that as JSON back to my
JavaScript client and now it can send
along that request token header name and
I can just decorate my API endpoints
with validate anti forgery token an
asp.net core takes care of the rest so
to compare the cookies to the requester
and make sure that everything is
protected embrace security policies
policy use if you probably know that
asp.net core did a a radical rewrite of
how security works some of it I think is
actually I'm not too happy with and it's
kind of weird having an authentication
property on the HTTP context I always
thought was a little bit weird it seem
to me like authentication should just be
another service that I can inject I
don't know if they'll change any of that
in the future but there's some
discussions on github that indicate they
might be changing that in the future
security security policies our policies
that you can apply to say I want to
check that this user is an admin or is
authenticated or has an email address
that is in the domain of my company and
you can encapsulate that rule into an
authorization policy like so just by
requiring claims I'm doing a build to
turn it into a policy and once you build
one of these authorization policies they
become very easy to use in an
authorization attribute which I'll get
to in just a second and for those of you
that haven't worked with claims botnet
core is very oriented toward claims that
was a move that started a few years ago
even though the full dotnet framework
but it's just the idea that a claim can
be any key value ter so what is my email
what is my name what organization is a
am i associated with and I admin or not
those are all claims that you can add
and if you have custom claims that you
want to add about a user in there's
extensibility points where you can go in
and add additional claims at the point
where the user is authenticated you
might need to do a database query to do
that and that's exactly what it was
designed to do but then once you have
that once you have understanding claims
you understand security policies what I
don't want to see in a dotnet core
application is someone to using the
authorized attribute and passing in a
string that describes which policy they
want to use I would much rather create a
custom authorization attribute that is
very clear that user is admin so that's
something that I could decorate a
controller or an action
and behind-the-scenes I don't know what
policy is using I don't really care when
I'm just implementing the controller but
behind the scenes I have some
flexibility now as to what claims that
will actually check and what policy that
will actually use so custom authorized
attribute let's talk about views how
many people still use HTML helpers any
asp.net chloride hip nobody OSU
I always liked asp.net MVC but I always
thought that was mmm excuse me the
absolute worst part of the MVC framework
HTML helpers tank helpers are much
better tag helpers for those that
haven't used them their process on the
server side but they are a lot like
angular 1 directors well they sit in
your HTML rate the razor engine can
detect them and you have the ability to
inject logic and change the markup when
these anti forgery sorry II type forgery
when these are tag helpers are in place
tag helpers can be attributes because
also the elements and they're relatively
easy to write as long as you're doing
something simple and I encourage people
to write their own tag helpers to take
care of removing some common markup that
might be inside of your views so this
would be a custom tank helper that looks
for an element my dash environment and I
could set name properties on that also
embrace view components anyone using to
use components in dotnet core such a few
review components or any feature in
previous versions of the asp.net if I
had to render a a hunk of markup inside
of a larger view if it was using the
same model as its parent view it was
easy to use a partial view and just say
render this partial and here's a model
to use but if I want to render of chunk
of HTML that's based on a completely
different model and I want to
unassociated with the parent view there
was a thing HTML dot action which would
call back into the controller action as
a child request and it worked most of
the time but there were some situations
where child actions child actions just
became very weird
child actions are basically gone in this
version of core what I can set up
instead is a view component so view
component is almost like a controller
because you're going you're going to
have a method invoked not as part of an
HTTP per class but it's a request from
from view and this method in though can
return views up sent well but pretty
much always return views but they can
return anything that's an IV component
resolved and the way I could use that is
let's say I want to encapsulate all this
HTML into something where I could just
say render the main menu and this thing
could inject its own services that it
needs to look up things in the database
and find out information about the user
there's meaning view component can do
that and all I need to do to render this
main view component from a razor view is
to do a weight component dot invoke
async that's what I have to do in 1.0
that's a really ugly syntax but that
would find the view component called
main menu call the invoke method pass I
can pass parameters there too and it
just spits out whatever HTML does that
view component told it to if you're
using 1.1 there's a tag helper BC that
allows you to render that view component
and is really quite nice now it looks
looks nice inside of the view too so
it's just another way to decompose a
complex view into simpler pieces and the
advantage of the view component there is
that it can again be completely
independent it can inject its own
services and figure out its own data
model to use client code every asp.net
core uses JavaScript these days chances
are you're using javascript that might
be starting to use things like a script
approach the echo script 2015 thought it
was over the jet lag but maybe not how
do you package and bundle that stuff
personally right now of all the tools
that are available
I prefer web pack it's just a tool that
I think works well with both the
JavaScript code as well as there's some
asp.net integration now that will talk
about how many people using web pad
good note any anyone else using
something else like roll up or
browserify now
so maybe I'm preaching to the choir use
webpack one of the reasons I like
webpack is I think the configuration
although it's a little bit difficult to
understand it first at the end of the
day it's a little bit simpler than some
of the other tools that are out there
basically you just need to tell web past
what thousand I'm looking at so look at
j/s files what modules do I want
included I'm going to be building a
bundle that includes react here and
what's the output where do I place the
output what j/s file and it also has
these new plugins this one unfortunately
names this dll plugin and it has a sneek
plugins that can do things like uglify
the code minify the code determine keep
track of what modules i've included here
that's what this dll plugin does keep
what keep track of what modules have
been included in this bundle so that
when I build a second bundle with my
application code these modules are not
included that's the idea build one file
with all the stuff that doesn't change
from bender's those other files that
contain my application code that are
changing all the time and I like
personally to use multiple configuration
files with webpack so I like to build
have one configuration file to build my
vendor bundle one to build all of my
test code one to build all of my
application code and just there's a
couple different opinions here that are
going on one opinion is that a lot of
people will use other tools like a test
runner so that when their XP ting their
unit tests the test runner will actually
do the compilation of module bundling of
things like typescript files I like to
do it all with lead pack and then the my
test runner I don't have to worry about
loading plug-ins to do that the neat
thing about web pack is it's executing
in their JAF so if I need to do things
like go out and find all of my TF files
that are inside of these features folder
I can do some programming there to just
find them all JavaScript services was a
project that was recently released by
Steve Sanderson and some others he
finished and working for Microsoft but
of not Jes name
and it works really well with webpack so
basically what you can do with with
JavaScript services it's a piece of
middleware that you can install into
your asp.net application so that if
you're using webpack to build and bundle
all this javascript code it can do hot
module reloading by talking to that
piece of middleware so that when you
save when you update a JavaScript file
or a typescript bond you save it to the
hard drive web pack detects that and
just communicates with my asp.net
application directly and says hey send
us a new chunk of JavaScript down to the
browser and just that need logic
disappears in the browser and I don't
lose any State and things just magic
just happens and it's really easy to use
you just install the middleware and what
happens behind the scenes is that this
middleware is the one that will actually
run web pack for me based on my
configuration files that I have
available the only downside to this is
that it happens silently now inside of
my asp.net server so something goes
horribly wrong for some reason this web
pack you'll occasionally get into these
situations where the the hot updates
don't come over and you have to refresh
the browser and sometimes restart your
server but it's worth it because it
makes the rest of the development cycle
so quick I use karma as a test runner
even if I'm not using angularjs karma
was a test runner developed by the
angular team but it works with anything
and you can use different test
frameworks like unit Jasmine mocha so I
use it for like react based projects
it's my opinion that this is the best
test runner that is out there it
requires very little configuration
basically just need to tell it what
files to load and it'll just run all my
tests and as I've already built all of
my tasks from tight script into
JavaScript the configuration can really
be just as simple go out and find all of
the J's files load them find out what I
specs load them and now it will
automatically launch Chrome and run my
unit tests there's a lot of things in
that core that require the command line
particularly when you get to client code
and using things like NPM and tools like
WebP at I don't like the built-in
command prompt in Windows so I tell
people do
con EU that's fixed con nu or commander
Cmdr that's probably what I have running
somewhere around here but it doesn't
want to come up area it can show me
things like the current branch I'm alone
and the project so it seems that I'm
inside of a git repository now on the
branch sprint QA there's nothing been
modified but if I were to touch a file
that would turn red
nice little indication the other next
thing it does which won't be a big
feature for anyone that uses something
like AI term on Mac OS is that you can
have split panels on it and this is
really nice when I want to run something
like a web pack build over here and
watch it and a build for my test over
here and watch it a my unit tests down
here and just watch for red to flash by
to see if a unit test field I can have
all the lives inside of one window at a
time and I can even write a little
script so the developers can launch that
process so this is the syntax to launch
con email and tell us to do an NPM one
run watch in one window then do an NPM
run test watch in a new console that is
split horizontally so bring up this
window and then NPM on karma in a new
console split vertically so bring up
this window and now I have those three
windows ready to go only downside to
this make make sure you put all of this
on the same line so don't actually put
line breaks in you have to stretch it
out across to the far right of the
editor client code layout I've struggled
with this a little bit quite honestly
but there's been some nice things that
have happened recently in the type's pro
type script world and the web pack world
that allow me to place my client code
wherever I want to so in an asp.net core
project but let's say I'm building
something with react or angular 2 I
could have a client folder and inside of
the client folder place things like not
only my CSS but also my script and I can
have modules in here components and
models and services
and you might say well what about
feature folders well typically what I've
been trying lately is that this client
folder which is a top-level folder in my
project will contain the reusable things
for the application so the things I need
to invoke services and API is back on
the server but in the features folder I
will have a little script file that will
bootstrap the components that are needed
that particular feature at least so in
the features folder just lift up CF HTML
file it's a little bit fancy it's not a
full spa but it needs to include this
list that main TSX file you need to have
that functionality and this but this
list file might pull in a bunch of stuff
from common components and models and
services hopefully this is all making
sense
another thing I've started to feel very
strongly about is using NPM only so I
want to use NuGet for everything that's
net and I'm going to use NPM for
everything that's Java scope and a lot
of Microsoft developers we've kind of
been encouraged to use Bower over the
years and I think there's a lot of that
still hanging around today I haven't
used our in about two years now what a
lot of people don't realize about NPM
although there's some scenarios where
it's not particularly good goes but it
can manage client-side libraries so if I
went to NPM install bootstrap the CSS
framework I can if I went to NPM install
jQuery I can I can certainly npm install
angular 2 and that means if I have
everything controlled by NPM I don't
have to worry about NPM and Bower I
don't have to worry about even typing
anymore because typescript types have
moved over to NPM repositories so I can
NPM and slow all types for Jasmine and
reacts and all those things that I need
so use NPM forget about Bower if you can
and by the way a lot of people say well
how do I tell the difference between
what what needs to execute on the server
and what needs to execute on the client
that it just doesn't bother me
jQuery o go to the client and karma is
something I use on the server but it all
comes down to NPM
I have been resistant to tight scripts
for a long time I tried using it but I
really got the feeling that it was
designed to write when J s programs for
Windows and I wasn't doing when J apps
but a few things have happened recently
which have made me accept type script
I've started to like it a lot more it's
actually a couple things that you can
see in this TS config file first of all
no implicit any still allows you to kind
of opt out of type script so if I don't
want to write type annotations
everywhere I don't have to another piece
and my drawing tools not working but
that's okay another piece in here that
is quite nice is model resolution model
module res resolution of note is
wonderful because now if i npm install a
library like react or angular q and I
start writing type script when I write
an import statement type script
automatically looks under new modules
and will find those modules I don't have
to do anything special or any other
configuration that's quite a mint quite
nice but if I do have a problem this
trace resolution flag will actually tell
me everywhere the kite script is looking
for something that I can either find or
not find so when I write an import
statement with es2015 or text rib it'll
tell me where it's looking I can also
customize my environment now so one of
the problems I have a type script in the
past is you just run into weird problems
where you use someone's library that is
using promises and tight script would
complain about not knowing what the
promises and you'd have to ensure
typescript that you are using a promise
library if promises don't exist now
there's this Lib configuration where you
can basically just tell typescript look
i'm program in the browser so assume I
have all the Dom types I'm programming
with es5 to make just assume that I will
have all of the es5 API is available and
by the way I'm also just assumed that I
have promises available so it does
complain if someone uses them and then
the other piece that's really wonderful
is this pass so with with pass that
three you can tell typescript I want to
also include this client script folder
when you're trying to resolve a module
so if I say something like import my
list widget
or imports too from my list widget type
script will know to look in the nude
modules folder but also to look out at
the client scripts folder to try to find
that widget and I have a lot more
control over what we're type script is
looking for things it's made a lot
easier to work with so now it's just a
problem of do I like all the type
annotations and if you use typescript in
the past and you've struggled with
either the PSD utility or the Taipings
utility trying to get pipe definitions
to typescript all of that stuff is in
the app types repository that you can
use with NPM now you don't have to
install any extra tools all you need is
NPM and I can install NPM install app
type slash Jasmine and poof typescript
will understand my Jasmine tests now no
additional work needed so all those
things are good I do something that
maybe is a little bit odd I don't know I
do all of my c-sharp work inside of
Visual Studio with resharper and I have
Visual Studio code open to the same
solution folder so that whenever I need
to add a type script or echo script 2015
stuff I can do that in code just code to
me feels looks still a little bit better
than Visual Studio for editing
JavaScript it's very good and those
plugins you can get to do all sorts of
wonderful things with your tight script
and equus code a lot of people ask me
where do I place my client code and
where do I build my code to and my
opinion is that the client code that you
cannot send it to client because it
hasn't been transpiled should be kept
outside of the www root folder or
whatever folder you are using to serve
files and then when you build it with
web pack or whatever tool you choose you
build it into the dub-dub-dub the root
folder and just have a consistent naming
scheme we're going to put it in a
distribution folder I like to call it
assets and it's inside of here where
everything that I've built with web pack
exists I think of it as my bin folder
for JavaScript
ah another little thing that I liked
that we did in one project was we would
need to instantiate some react code to
run on a page and pass it some
parameters and was just going to do a
few simple things on that page but
actually come up just with the data -
parameter and serialize my model into
that HTML attribute so that react to
easily grab that data and not have to go
back to the server and now what about
unit testing I think having a single
unit test project for your solution or
your application is a fine thing all
depends on your project in your solution
Microsoft takes the approach where they
want get one unit testing project per
production project right so they have a
lot of test projects which I think is
fine for open source projects like that
and open source projects where different
projects build into different new gets
and there have to be very public about
it but for a business application I
think it's okay to have one test
assembly but just has folders for each
of the projects out here that I need to
test whether it's three or five or ten I
like using X unit with dotnet core I
think it's extensible it's open source
this was ceremony they do a good job
keeping it up with all the changes and I
like the vocabulary action is the best I
like writing facts instead of decorating
things with test method but that's just
my opinion
I try very hard to avoid mocks in my
unit test and if you go out on the
internet you'll find lots of debate
about that I'm not going to cover it
here but I simply I refuse to use a
mocking library and that's my opinion
I don't like mocks what I do like is
what some people would not call a unit
test but let me explain this slowly so
first of all out there one of the pieces
of infrastructure that Microsoft
provides in a github repository and as a
nougat package as a thing called the
asp.net for test toast anyone uses just
it's a wonderful piece that you can use
inside of your unit test so what you
want to do so ostensibly what asp.net
Court éstos is about is it's about this
situation I have to start a class that
configures a bunch of middleware how
would I ever test that request and
information are flowing through the
middleware correctly that's something
that the asp.net core test host can do
it can basically set up an HTTP
processing pipeline and you can send off
a request through this test host it just
stays in memory it doesn't actually have
to open a socket or go anywhere and it's
a lot like an Web API when you had that
in memory channel that you could route
requests through an example of using it
would be that I had some different code
here what if I want to test a bit of
functionality that I want in my
application like an ajax login redirects
to the return URL and turn an ajax login
redirect if it's an ajax ajax request I
actually wanted to return with a few
hundred status code and the redirect
instruction in the location header how
could I test that little bit of thing
well I can instantiate an asp.net core
test toast it's relatively simple in
this example it's wrapped inside of a
method called create server but I'm
going to place some little we're inside
of create server some cookie health
education and send a response send a
request right there so send async a
request to example.com make it look like
it's an ajax request and then i can
write a search against the response and
here's another example create a server
create a client issue an HTTP GET
request to this URL see if i got that
ready write status feedback so this
asp.net core test toes is one part of my
solution let me tell you about another
part if you are using entity framework
or and has this in-memory provider
anyone using that I'm curious anyone
using es core anyone avoiding es yeah
on some projects I use and it's okay but
this in-memory provider is actually
quite nice I can say I want to new DD
contacts and I can add things to it and
I can query this DB context and all the
data stays in memory doesn't actually
get a sequel server this is not to use
as a production in memory database they
make that very clear it doesn't support
a lot of scenarios and it will break on
you and it doesn't quite obey the
semantics of what a real relational
database would do its sole purpose in
life is to give you something that you
can write unit tests against the entity
framework with the one thing to be aware
of make sure I have this one of slide ah
yeah
let me back up a second the one thing to
be aware of is this different people
approach the in-memory provider with
different expectations of how it should
behave some people expect that if they
create a new dbcontext object that they
would have a new in-memory database but
that's not how EF in-memory provider
works the way it works is you create
your first DB context and yes there's a
new in-memory database now and you add
things to it you can query it and if you
create another dbcontext over here in a
different test it will use that same
database which isn't quite what we want
for tasks but at least that's what some
people think but in reality it is I need
to be able to call the way I would use
this as I call into a component that's
in my application that uses the entity
framework it's going to instantiate a DB
context and it's writing data it has no
idea that this is just in memory but
once my application component is
finished in my unit tests I want to be
able to instantiate a DB context and
query that in-memory data that it's
stored and so that scenario works every
dbcontext you create will you sustain in
memory database but you can can can
clear out that database between tests
what you need to do is just configure
things correctly with the internal
service provider so that every time you
when you explicitly ask for it excuse me
this class that I have set up DB
instance
it will create a new didi context for me
that will reboot the in-memory database
that's being used so clear it out
between tests and that's why back here
Andres unit tasks I will just construct
a new instance every time this class is
created therefore every unit tests will
have a new in-memory database to work
with but that makes sense so where I'm
going with all of this is that the
combination of the asp.net quartet toast
and the es in-memory provider actually
gives me the ability to write from what
some a lot of people would consider
integration tests so I'm going to
instantiate my entire application or
maybe instantiate my entire controller
and I'm not going to try to mock
anything out or fake or stub anything
out I'm just going to use this in memory
es provider so that when I tell my
controller to create something I'm going
to go in and make sure that thing got
into the database somehow so just I
begin a test now it's more of an
integration test it's the controller
that's going to use mediator and it's
going to use command Handler and all
these things are going to be going on
but it's very little code to give me a
reasonably high expectation that my
application is actually working because
it's exercising the whole thing and
really the point of unit testing
controllers when you use mediators is on
this new point they're just
orchestrators at that point there's hand
messages around so this gives me a nice
high level view of is my application
working or not and now just a few simple
tips top T char code so if you're using
dotnet core and you want to go
cross-platform simple tip would be
always use environment new line instead
of hard-coding a / r / r / n there's how
to work across platforms always use past
combine when you're building up a
fascinating - a file that's on the file
system and be aware of the different
environment variable names that are used
on Linux vs. Mac OS versus Windows like
if you wanna get the home environment
get the home directory for a user
and then last thing kind of unrelated to
this I've started to have an intense
dislike for the convention of applying
the async suffix to an async method does
anyone else have that just like at least
one person so I think it's useful if you
have legacy code that has synchronous
methods so a method like get account and
now moving forward you need to provide
two different methods you need to keep
that synchronous method there so you
don't break old clients but you need to
provide an asynchronous version for
people that want to do a sync
programming so fine adding get account
async method because the only differ in
the return type and we all know you
can't overload c-sharp methods just
based on the return type but if you're
not in that situation you're building a
brand new API something that does a sign
out tenant I don't want to see the async
suffix there I can look at this method
and see it returns a task and that's
enough for me to know that it's
asynchronous and I really think this
boils down to and well and there you can
see the Microsoft API and up async this
really boils down to I saw this blog
post a couple months ago about a talk
that the orange juice trip did on
channel 9 where he said when I'm
designing the C++ language for new
people for new features people insist on
loud explicit syntax and I think when a
single wait was introduced in c-sharp we
wanted loud explicit syntax to say this
is an async method but we've reached the
point now that this is pretty much an
established feature there's a lot of
people building AP is now where they
don't offer synchronous methods they're
all it's only async and I would rather
have the terse notation and not have to
type out sign out tenant user a thing in
fact I wish there was an easy way to get
rid of tasks and the async keyword too
but it's just a dream anyway that's all
I have and a couple hopefully within a
couple of weeks I'm going to list all
these things out in a blog post so maybe
and with links so if you want to find
out more information because I sift
through these things too fast but
otherwise you feel free to send me an
email and I guess I had a few minutes
for questions
okay I'll be hanging out thank you for
coming
[Applause]